So God's upset because he had made man
on earth and it grieved him at his
heart,
and God says,
I will destroy man,
whom I've created from the face of the
earth,
both man and beast and the creeping
thing and the fowls of the air for I
repent that I've made them.
But Noah found grace in the eyes of the
Lord.
Okay,
so that's an interesting thing.
So here what we have is the question is
the whole world's in chaos at this
point,
right in this point in the story.
And the chaos is multiple sorts.
It's,
it arose from the fall.
It rose from the emergence of self
consciousness.
It emerged.
Safe arose from the sins of cane,
like things are not going well.
It's multiple levels of collapse.
And it's got to the point where God
saying this is a mess,
like it's such a mess that the whole
thing has to be washed away.
The first fall wasn't enough.
Even canes collapse wasn't enough.
We're going to just scrub the whole
bloody thing clean.
So it's,
it's the ultimate in traumatic
collapses.
The question is,
well,
what do you do in the face of the
ultimate in traumatic collapses?
And the answer is in the story.
So Noah is someone who finds fate,
who finds favor in the eyes of God,
so he's like able.
There's something that Noaa is doing
right that's going to enable him to ride
out the storm.
And so the question here,
it's the same question.
Do you want to have a life where there's
no storms
or do you want to have a life where you
can ride out the storms?
That's the issue,
right?
Are you behind the dikes or do you build
a boat?
Do you captain the boat?
That's the same idea.
So the idea here is that the thing that
rides out the chaos is the thing that
builds and captains the boat.
It's another dominance hierarchy idea.
What should be at the top?
Well,
the top of something that doesn't get
flooded out as well.
What should be at the top?
Well,
it's to be the boat builder and to be
the captain of the boat,
it's not to be hidden from the flood.
Precisely.
And so,
I mean,
here's,
here's something to think about,
identity,
identity politics,
because that's what we're up to our neck
yet,
okay,
are you who you are?
Can I box you?
Will,
will you accept that as an identity?
So I could do that.
Lots of ways.
You're male,
your Asia,
you're young,
right?
There's things about you that I can
derive because of your putative
membership in a set of different groups.
The problem with doing that is that the
number of groups that I can assign
youtube is without.
And so I have to pick arbitrary groups
to assign you to and you can accept that
if you want,
but there's no evidence that those are
the proper canonical groups.
But maybe you're happy about that
because now you've been assigned
membership in a group and that's your
identity.
Okay?
So the question is,
well,
fine,
what happens when that identity is blown
into pieces?
Then what?
Well,
here's,
here's the answer to some degree,
and this is the answer that's embedded
in the story of Noah.
If you want it withstand chaos.
Do you want to be who you are or do you
want to be the thing that changes who
you are constantly.
That's the question and that's the
difference.
That's the difference.
There's a categorical difference in
identity.
Are you who you are or are you the thing
that could continually be more than you
are and that's the thing that isn't the
stable identity.
It's not the initial state.
It's also not the state of being in
chaos that nihilistic state,
let's say,
and it's not even the state of
reformulation that occurs after you've
gone through the process.
It's the state of continually going
through the process so you can identify
with the thing that trends you could
identify,
identify with the thing that you are or
you can identify with the thing that
transforms who you are.
Right,
and that's the same as the state
subjugating itself to the individual
because the individual is the thing that
transforms the state and what the state
should do the states necessarily because
obviously it organizes all of us into
peaceful cooperation and competition,
the states necessary.
Then the question is,
is the state the highest good?
And the answer to that is,
well,
it can't be because it's old and dead
and blind,
and so if the state becomes the highest
good,
then you're occupied by the spirit of
something that's old and dad and blind.
Well,
that's not only not good for you because
then you're old and dead and blind,
but it's also bad for the state because
as soon as the state gets old and dead
and blind,
God gets unhappy with it and the chaos
comes in and washes it away.
So it seems like a bad solution.
So what's the proper solution?
You subordinate your group identity to
the identity that transforms your
identity,
right?
And this state subordinates.
It's power to the vision and
articulation of the individual because
that's what revives the state.
And so that's what these stories are
trying to stumble towards.
Roughly speaking.